I'm pretty sure this won't go well I
took French in high school but I didn't
really pay attention I took French for
three years I already know I'm gonna
fail mile nollie my yay maybe just may
mile my it's really pretty
no matter how you say it so far Jeff
like Jeffrey but it's Jeff Lee jofre
Joffrey Golf Roy I think the next one is
Jeffrey gonna go with Jeffrey oh I'm so
wrong I should have known coming into a
French thing that at some point I'd be
asked to make the wah sound dead person
I want to say cappuccino cappuccino
Kapusta cap machine cat [ __ ] cat [ __ ]
I was hoping that's gonna be copper to
me sounds like a [ __ ] thanks give me
that one yo-yo ma
this one I'm I've seen this name before
and I can never pronounce it off the bat
but then when you hear it you're like oh
right get on me
Guillaume yum yum
this is gray and iam not even close I'm
not very good at this ladies yeah oh
jeez this is late sia
I imagine it's at the end Leticia
Leticia lady Rhea like deep yeah leticia
yeah see if I had a French accent its
sound probably accurate the dots that
always throws people off you know like
what are the dots what do they mean your
favor
what there's a V in the middle and two
consonants they said there's leather
breathe Missa bring live Pam Lefebvre
Levin how do you get that there's a B
and an R in here my mother's gonna be
very disappointed that I don't know
these French words sure Maggie I stop
slowly trying to say this name Chevalier
Chevalier
this is Chevrolet Chevrolet like the car
shooby a civil air shiver lay I got this
one though Chevalier I'm sound like
anything I just said oh wait I'll give
my
that one all of these names are
inherently sexier sounding than ours
I thought honest I'd come in here being
like oh I kind of know French I don't
know me
congratulations France you got pretty
names and I can't say him
[Music]
[Applause]